The end of an era today in New York.
One of the last of the public phones was taken away,...
…while some private phones will still be around.
CBS Dick Brennan shows us the ones,...
…you see on the streets will largely be gone.
It's last call for public payphones.
At 49th and 7th, a few of these technological dinosaurs were hauled away,...
…while fittingly stared down by a T-Rex on a billboard.
But it's not quite the end of the line for these landlines.
Some would be sticking around.
Do you know what that is?
No.
No?
Try explaining a pay phone to someone born 6 years ago.
It's like an old-fashioned cellphone.
Yeah, it's like a phone.
I mean, this is a phone.
It's a phone, sometimes.
You will still find private pay phones,...
…and these four phone booths which will be preserved,...
…on West End Avenue between 66th and 101st streets.
But, even if some locals who remember when,...
…want no part of them, now.
When was the last time you used that pay phone?
That pay phone? Never. Zero!
Before the cellphone era, you could find a pay phone practically on every block.
It's a relic of an era that was so common around here.
But eventually, they didn't even work for Superman.
Still, some can't resist the draw of the old-fashioned, folding,...
...so-called the Superman booth.
So, I love this.
Come on. How much do I want?
You want everything?